[Music]
oh my god
hey guys it's inka so as some of you
might know a while ago my friend a day
has been asking me to mix a bunch of
things together
like every kind of cookie makes every
kind of cereal every kind of cake mix to
form
into completely new creations and this
time knowing how much i love fruit
he has asked me to mix every single kind
of fruit he could possibly find
into a pie he just dropped off a giant
box of fruits
i don't really know what's in there yet
so let's open it up
watermelon yellow watermelon bananas
figs
plantain prickly pear lump nectarine
kiwi lemon pomegranate peach orange
mango a soursop date squints
one of this is a tangerine one of this
is a mandarin
grapefruit apple pear green grapes
two little things of lychee long ends
guava smush to dragon fruits got a
coconut i don't know how to break this
open yet but i will
jujubes a lime strawberries some
raspberries
blackberry blueberry a velvet
apricot cherries and avocado
because avocado is a fruit
passion fruit which i'm super pumped
about rambutans
breadfruit cantaloupe pineapple we have
this korean melon
papaya honeydew korean pears
tomatoes which is surprisingly
also a fruit and not a vegetable so yes
there will be tomato in this pie
okay there's three more these are frozen
so i almost forgot but
acerola jackfruit and
of course some durian
there's literally so much fruit what i'm
gonna do now
is basically cut up every single kind of
fruit here
[Applause]
[Music]
this is what i have right now you guys
can see this is a full picture
of all the different kinds of fruit
what i'm gonna do now is actually toss
each type of fruit
into this bowl and i'm gonna add
just a little bit of sugar and macerate
the fruit
and then just let the juices drain so
then
my pie won't be crazy soggy hopefully
that juice i can condense it again
back into a syrup that will be like this
glorious
50 different type of fruit syrup i am
still starting on a fairly
normal note the apple and pear will
hopefully help balance
the crazy out i think my only experience
with plantains is the deep fried ones
i am curious to know how it's going to
taste in pie
generally for pie i know we try to avoid
like super watery fruit
and watermelon is literally water
papaya does have a softer texture so i
feel like this is just going to
completely disintegrate in the pie but
bananas
probably going to add a bit of
creaminess cherries
i love passion fruit i almost want it to
taste more like passion fruit than
anything else all my berries
plums beautiful color dates dates are
very chewy though
not really sure how that's gonna add
next up we have some guava which is
again
just smells really nice like slightly
floral velvet apricot it almost looks
like apricot jam
at this point which i think is not a bad
thing at all so
tropical flavors i think it's gonna be
really nice in the pie
what's gonna be not so nice are
these tomatoes even though tomato itself
isn't savory for some reason when i
think of tomatoes i just think of savory
things
could be good it could be really bad but
this is going in there
this is some sour stuff i'm gonna try
actually a little bit
there's like some sort of floral notes
to it i feel like this could be really
good bread fruit i've never had as well
it has like almost like a spongy texture
it smells really nice
prickly pear the only time i've had
prickly pear was in a margarita
rambutan this is what it looks like on
the outside it's like a little alien
it's almost like finding a pearl on the
inside in
chinese cuisine we use long in
for a lot of desserts so i feel like it
could work
a bit of green avocado avocado and
condensed milk is actually a really good
dessert
it could potentially add a creaminess to
the pie
fakes are also not too crazy in dessert
fig jam is one of my favorite jams so
korean melon very similar to i think
like honeydew and cantaloupe it does
have
a slightly crunchier texture quince
which is known as being like a crossover
between apple and pear
i feel like a pie made just with quince
might be really good
korean pear absolutely love just like
very juicy
jujube one of the things that we use for
desserts
a lot mango probably my most favorite
fruit
tangerine and also mandarin give it a
little bit of
citrusy burst jackfruit it looks very
much like durian on the outside
a very pungent smell not opposed to it
just not sure how it is in pie
next up oh durian my mom always said
the stronger smelling a durian is the
better it's gonna taste and i completely
agree
this one that i bought specifically is
from malaysia
and it is known for being extremely
potent in terms of smell so
it's probably going to be amazing that's
going in you know how they normally add
like lemon juice to
fruits for fruit pie this is kind of the
same concept this is lime
and the rest of my citrus fruits
pomegranates
squeeze in there and then i have the
acerola puree
which is my last fruit now for our
gorgeous bowl of fruits i am going to
add sugar in here
and mix it up i'm gonna eyeball this
part
because i feel like we already have so
much sweetness
i feel like the strong smelling fruits
are really standing out so the durian
the jackfruit
looks pretty interesting right now let
it chill for a little bit
wait until it releases all that juice
strain it
and go from there so this is what my
fruit looks like right now
it has been sitting for a while
and this is the amount of juice it gave
me
so it's not that much juice compared to
let's say if
i did the same process to apples but i
am still going to reduce it over the
stove top after that's done
and cooled i can then put it in the pie
looks like this right now it's very
gooey very ooblecky
smells a little bit interesting i almost
feel like i get a little bit of tomato
you know when you're making tomato sauce
i'm gonna taste it really quick
[Music]
okay it's very sweet because of
obviously the added sugar
but i am getting notes of jackfruit
[Music]
i'm so confused because it just tastes
like you know when you have like a fruit
smoothie and it's just like a
combination of everything
anyways go ahead and add this into the
fruit
so far so good i feel like they've
softened a little bit
which is nice suddenly it smells like
jackfruit and durian again so i guess
the strong smelling ones
really do win over but we will see what
it looks like
after i pop it in the oven just go ahead
and put my filling in
it actually looks pretty good i am now
going to
just do a lattice pie
crust this so far is looking pretty good
though
i will say brush a final layer of egg
wash on there
final sprinkle of sugar on top i'm gonna
pop this in the oven
goodbye pie see you later
so while i'm waiting for the pie to bake
i'm also curious to know
what just combining straight up 50 types
of fruit is going to taste like so
there's no sugar in this one which means
we'll taste
how sweet i guess the combined fruits
are
let's uh blend this up
i love this color smells like durian
[Music]
oh it's just so interesting the first
taste i got was durian and banana but
then
it started melting into like apples
and like pears i got that kind of
sweetness
the aftertaste is very similar to just
like your average
berry banana smoothie 50 kinds of fruit
is not cheap to buy but
it is surprisingly very good
all right my pie is done it looks
surprisingly
pretty amazing it looks like an actual
fruit pie so i'm very excited but now i
have to
let it cool for at least four hours so
i'm gonna taste this
first thing in the morning tomorrow the
pie has been chilling in the fridge
overnight so it's completely set now and
i'm so excited to show you guys
what it looks like right now because it
actually looks like a normal fruit pie
[Music]
i'm actually going to now give some of
this pie to a day who's here to pick it
up
and so then we can taste test it
together
this is going to be an interesting test
for me
cheers
you know what this tastes and smells
like to me um
fruit roll-ups like it reminds me of
school this is like this is really good
right you know how critical i am i feel
like i'm getting
like a very sweet tomato but it's not
unpleasant because of all the sugar i
added in have you ever had like a
vitamin gummy
it's like that like it's like a
combination of different flavors things
that i can't identify
like all of the fruit that i know but
there are taste
in this pie that i'm not familiar with
but i feel like i should
try some of these individually and see
what i think but together
together they work did it again did a
great job you've been satisfied by taste
buds and like
honestly that's like the most difficult
task for anybody
okay so i guess this is it i have almost
finished my pie at this point i actually
really like it
another challenge down let us know what
else you want to see us mix next time
and we'll try to make it happen all
right
see ya
[Music]
you